good morning John there is too much
confusion about how to be a human in the
world today as an example I present to
you the 49 emails we have received at
the dear Hank and John email address
that include the word airplane and see
these questions are about armrest
etiquette and plugs and people who won't
stop talking but above all they are
about the eternal debate to recline or
not to recline in short one half says
this is my seat there is a button on it
and I can go back and the other half
says it's your seat but like this space
is my space and you coming into it is at
least a little bit rude this was
inflamed this week by a video that is
strong contender for the most annoying
thing I've ever seen I'm fairly long I'm
not overly so I come in here on this
ground even so when someone reclines
their seat into my space I do find that
I sometimes need to immediately
rearrange myself or get stuck with my
leg pinned up to my chest now this is of
course not HUP dong by the fact that I'm
almost always wearing bulky hiking shoes
because I am a dad but at the same time
my length enos means that I do feel
comfortable if I am able to recline some
time and so sometimes I will look behind
me and say can I is it and then if they
say no that's ok sometimes it's a child
that I don't ask cuz you're a child
that's but-but-but-but-but reason this
is a thing now is that over the last 20
or 30 years airplane seats have changed
dramatically between the same point on a
chair in the next chair there used to be
like 36 inches that is shrunk to on
average about 31 and as little as 28
this is accomplished in two ways one is
by making the seats physically thinner
and thus more uncomfortable look at
these seats this is ridiculous it's
awful accomplished by decreasing the
amount of space between you and the
thing in front of your face now of
course this is all done so that more
seats can fit on a plane so that the
airline can sell more tickets so that
they can make more money selling cheaper
tickets because now price comparison
sites make airlines extremely price
competitive the only good news is that
it does make airplanes more carbon
efficient per passenger mile so
basically it's an effect of the
commodification of the airplane seat
without any regard for how good that
seat is going to be whose fault is that
the airline's priceline.com me all of us
and just by accident it's good for the
planet unsurprisingly there is more
tension around this issue than there
used to be but that is not
what I find to be the interesting thing
about this whenever we are brought into
close proximity with strangers we
discovered that we might have slight
differences in how we understand the
world that can nonetheless lead to
significant disagreement in a world
where we less and less commonly share
spaces with strangers we get less good
at dealing with that conflict and when
we don't have good methods for resolving
conflict or dealing with imperfect
situations and we end up angry and
behaving in irrational ways and going
viral on Twitter and no one wants that
the solution it's actually very simple
say this with me I disagree with people
about airplane seats and that is okay
they understand the world differently
than I do and that is okay if a person
takes the time and energy to ask me for
a favor I will take a deep breath and
assume that they are acting in good
faith even if I am annoyed even if I
think they are being dopey and entitled
because society must function and
because I cannot truly know their story
and because if we cannot share the metal
sky-bird what can we share and because
going viral on Twitter sucks John I will
see you on Tuesday
and if you want to see John and I answer
good questions like this one often
better questions than this one come see
dear Hank and John live also the
Anthropocene reviewed live the events
are emceed by a Minotaur what else could
you ask for
March 9th in Columbus Ohio March 10th in
Carmel Indiana March 11th I'll be
talking without John and I'll be in
college in Michigan about climate change
in the Internet and March 12th in Ann
Arbor Michigan